So the great thing about reports is, they don't necessarily have to be
turned into charts. You can keep them as reports too. but before we can
turn it into a chart, we have to change the report type. because right
now, if you see next to the preview we're set to the tabular format.
>> huh.
>> And the tabular format is the simplest type
of report, which is what we're looking at right now.
>> huh.
>> Just simple like a spreadsheet. But
you can't actually turn that into a dashboard.
>> Okay.
>> So, if we click the other report types.
>> Summary
>> Summary, which is
really similar to tabular, but it just adds a little grouping
for you to be able to more granularly categorize the data.
>> Can I click it and see what you mean?
>> Yeah. 'Kay, so what do you mean by grouping? Like, what could I group on?
>> So, maybe one thing that we'd want to group by,
instead of doing it the way we have now, is if
you take that Ticket Type field, just grab it from the
header, and then drag it into where it says Drag Field Here.
>> Uh-huh. Oh, cool.
>> And so now what it's going to do, yeah. It separates all of the different
ticket types to, these are all of the ones for our VIP. And then it'll give you
a little subtotal for how much has been spent
on VIP and then same thing for General Admission.
>> That's really cool.
>> And there will be a grand total at the bottom.
>> Okay there is no grand total.
>> Well, there will be, but this is just a preview.
>> okay, so that's pretty cool. that's summary, what were the other ones?
>> So the other ones are matrix, which is
really similar to summary, but you can also create groupings
on the left-hand side. So, that's why it's a matrix,
you can do it along the top and the side.
>> Okay.
>> And, then joined is kind of just a
culmination of a bunch of reports that you can
then just be able to show different types of
data in different ways, but have one huge report.
>> Okay, okay. So, how do we, how do we go
from this summary report to that, our nice little gauge dashboard?
>> Yeah. So, what you want to do is we want
to click Save One More Time because when
you run the report, it doesn't actually save it.
>> Okay.
>> After it saves, click on Report.
>> Okay, so here's our report. And we've got our VIP ticket type, total
spent for each person. You know, I would have liked a sum total down here.
>> Yeah, I totally forgot the last step. So, let's go
back into the, our Report Editor by just clicking Customize here.
>> Okay.
>> And it will take us right back to the view we were
in before. So what we care about is the total spent column, right?
>> Um-hmm.
>> So let's actually drag that to the end, just so it
kind of keeps that separate and we can see the total on the right.
>> Okay.
>> And then click that little arrow, and then what we're
going to do is we're going to want to summarize this field.
>> Okay, that makes sense.
>> And then click Sum so it'll create a total for each of those.
>> Yeah.
>> And now we can see it's going to sum up all
of the VIPS. All of the General Admissions,
and we'll have a grand total at the bottom.
>> Okay, so I'm going to save and run Report again.
>> Yes.
>> All right. We've got $14,600 bucks from VIP
tickets and then $28,000 or so on the General Admission.
>> Nice.
>> Okay. That's cool. So now if I go
to the bottom, okay, keeps track of the total amount.
And I'm guessing this is, I mean, I know
that this is the number that somehow has to feed
into our little, our gauge thing.
>> Exactly.